miles de israelíes Ultra nacionalistas
muchos de ellos provenientes de los
asentamientos judíos de si Jordania
ocupada atraviesan la puerta de Damasco
para conmemorar la captura israelí de
Jerusalén este en 1967 esta
controvertida marcha de las banderas
atraviesa el barrio musulmán de la
ciudad vieja con algunos cánticos
algunos de ellos racistas y también se
han producido algunos pequeños
incidentes todo esto es visto por los
palestinos como una provocación y un
intento de desplazarlos de la ciudad más
de tres mil policías se han desplegado
para garantizar el desarrollo de esta
marcha que además ha forzado a los
palestinos a cerrar sus comercios en la
ciudad vieja y a prácticamente vaciar
sus calles además de enfrentarse a
distintos bloqueos para que no se
produzcan distintos cruces este año
además estos grupos de extrema derecha
están alentados por la presencia de
ministros dentro de la coalición de
Benjamín y taniaku como es el caso de
itamar benjivir el ministro de seguridad
o besaré de motrich quien se encarga de
finanzas más temprano también cientos de
judíos accedieron a la Explanada de las
mezquitas un espacio reservado al culto
musulmán entre ellos un ministro y
varios legisladores de la coalición todo
esto aumenta las altas tensiones después
de los cinco días de enfrentamientos
entre Israel y la chica de islámica
Palestina que se saldaron con 35 muertos
en total y una tregua que entró en vigor
en sábado en los grupos palestinos
también han advertido sobre la
realización de esta marcha y posibles
respuestas si las cosas se salen de
control Por otra parte algunos grupos de
izquierda y activistas contra la
ocupación han organizado contra
manifestaciones un grupo intentó cortar
una de las de los caminos que unen los
asentamientos de Jordania ocupada con
Jerusalén mientras que otro grupo unas
pocas cuadras se ha reunido en bajo la
Consigna de evitar esta marcha para
rechazar esta marcha que califican de
fascista y demostración violenta de
supremacía